state border crossing prohibited reads
the signs separating Poland and Belarus
Poland is a member of NATO
Belarus is closely allied with Russia
but has kept its troops out of the war
in Ukraine so far but thousands of
Wagner mercenaries now based in that
country are training belarussian troops
those exercises are taking place right
on the Polish border
Poland responded by deploying more than
a thousand troops East these are
hardened war criminals so of course any
polish government would be concerned and
the first duty of any government is to
protect its external border
international border and the people on
our side
warsaw's response was met with somewhat
of a history lesson from the Russian
president
it was thanks to the Soviet Union thanks
to steps taken by Stalin that Poland got
substantial territories in the west
German land this is a fact Western
polish territories are Stalin's gift to
Poland
have our friends in Warsaw forgotten
about it we'll give them a reminder
when I put me
the makeup of Poland's territories is a
part of European history worth taking a
look at
August 1939 just a week before Nazi
Germany's troops crossed the border into
Poland Adolf Hitler and Joseph Stalin
signed a non-aggression pact effectively
carving Poland in half as each Army
invaded from either side
it bought the Soviet Union two years
before Hitler focused his sights on
invading that country in 1941. at the
end of the second world war Poland's
borders changed significantly with its
pre-war Frontier shifting further west
to incorporate parts of defeated Nazi
Germany this was Stalin's so-called gift
Putin was referring to
but former head of NATO's Allied command
retired General Philip Breedlove says
Putin's comments about Poland may be
just a distraction have the world's
press now start talking about these
exercises and stop talking about his
failures in Ukraine
here on the Polish border with Belarus
people are concerned the war games going
on just kilometers away could mean
something worse for their country
Michael Apple Al Jazeera